[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue tout
de suite notre sommeil en images avant
de découvrir nos invités alors de poids
allons nous parler aujourd'hui est bien
de la communication des manuels macron
cela semble tanguer au sommet de
l'elysée en ce moment entre aix et de
solennité voire de condescendance et
skill décontracté devoir relâcher la
politique du en même temps n'est pas
toujours évidente à raconter aux
français alors le roman du quinquennat
commence-t-il à s'essouffler nous
verrons tout cela nous parlerons aussi
du medef le medef qui a un nouveau
président geoffroy roux de bézieux élu
ce matin la tête du syndicat patronal
mais un président pour quoi faire c'est
là toute la question
nous demanderons donc si le président ou
de bézieux réussir à exister face au
président macron blues malaise ma lettre
les termes ne manquent pas pour décrire
la situation critique parmi les forces
de l'ordre
les rapports s'empilent et le dernier en
date fait par le sénat réclame des
perspectives pour la police et s'en
prend directement au juge souvent jugés
laxistes
enfin un sujet qui fait beaucoup parler
celui de la place des hommes dans les
sociétés occidentales
il aurait de plus en plus de mal à
exister à trouver leur place dans des
sociétés elles de plus en plus
égalitaire cela commence à être étudiés
de près aux états unis et ça porte un
nom la crise de la masculinité
alors est ce la disparition programmée
du mâle blanc on va voir tout cela sur
tous ces sujets vous vous exprimez vous
posez vos questions sur twitter sur
lefigaro.fr il y a matière à débat alors
on y va bonjour lucich matin merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes co
président de la fondation verte
européenne
après avoir fait la politique d'abord au
ps puis europe ecologie les verts
vous avez certainement un avis sur
toutes ces questions il est sûrement
tranché on sera ravi de l'entendre
bonjour philippe heure là merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes journaliste à rfi
vous êtes de nationalité britannique et
vous enseigner le journalisme bilingue
a la sorbonne nouvelle tout doit être
merci merci beaucoup marie visot aussi
d'être là pour le côté figaro vous êtes
chef de service au figaro économie en
charge de la politique économique et des
finances publiques notamment
bonjour ivan rioufol hauteur du bloc noc
le vendredi vous avez souvent la dent
dure pour emmanuel macron et vous avez
publié d'ailleurs macron la grande
mascarade bloc notes de 2016-2017 assez
paru chez l'artilleur l'année dernière
ça tombe bien puisque nous allons tout
de suite parlé de la politique de
communication d'emmanuel macron cette
communication elle ferait des couacs
elle sonnerait faux c'est la petite
musique qu'on entend partout ces
derniers jours une communication moins
harmonieuse qu'au début désordonnée
voire illisibles sur cette communication
et ses dessous vous en apprendrez vous
saurez tout en lisant le figaro deux
mains qui consacre trois pages
nous on en parle tout de suite mais
avant on regarde benjamin griveaux
c'était ce matin le porte parole du
gouvernement était l'invité de rmc
emmanuel macron c'est le pouvoir de
l'apparence
je les vrais ou faux nom d'un dieu les
pouvoirs des remontrances publiques le
voir des petites phrases préparer c'est
le tas tuerait tu dié c'est le nom long
et c'est ce qui sans doute et femmes
aujourd'hui je le dis à la classe et
d'une partie de la classe politique
française qui
qu'est ce que fait de manière très
confortable elle est dans l'instant est
donc l age en légumes
la petite phrase la petite mesure etc
quand nous avons fait le choix de
transformer durablement le pays ça prend
du temps
yvan magny mâcon la politique du temps
long des petites phrases
je descends pas dire d'autant que quand
j'ai fait ce livre quand j'ai commencé à
l'écrire et bien non et en essayant de
comprendre de ses dents d'expliquer
qu'il y avait effectivement une
mascarade une théâtre au cra si derrière
ce personnage c'était bien pour montrer
qu'il y avait beaucoup de vide
et effectivement ce vide était remplie
par la communication et cette
communication d'ailleurs elle est très
bien fait en effet parce qu'elle laisse
à penser qu'il serait dans l'air du
temps de mon point de vue il n'est pas
dans l'air du temps
il va même à rebours de l'air du temps
parce que l'on voit apparaître
aujourd'hui ce sont des en même temps
des contradictions dans sa communication
même c'est à dire que tout démarre tout
départ il avait il avait conçu une
communication comme étant celle du
silence
là c'est celle du bavarde à la rareté
selon jacques la rareté l'éloignement
enfin le juge
rien la posture hiératique ensuite ça a
été naturellement le bavardage un petit
peu pour ne rien dire et puis ensuite on
l'a vu très récemment on a eu deux
images qui se sont un peu contredite
également celles où il a fait la leçon à
ce jeune gavroche en disant qu'ils
m'appellent nous aviez du mal que vous
attend s'ils m'appellent monsieur le
président et puis quelques jours plus
tard il s'est fait prendre en photo avec
un groupe de techno pour le moins
vulgaire avec dents sur qui on est que
la fête de la musique ont exploité la
quille on les laissait voir des laissé
entendre des paroles du m'interdit de
donner ici et donc il y avait à chaque
donc ce message d'un président de la
république qui qui voulait sa
respectabilité et d'un autre côté ce
message d'un personnage branchouille est
donc là aussi il ya des contradictions
donc on ne voit pas très bien et je
pense qu'il navigue à vue et qu'il ne
sait peut-être même pas lui-même où il
habite le siège pittefaux répondu yvan
est un des éléments au débat c'est on
peut le dire une communication certes
peut-être mal à droite on en débat mais
40% toujours d'opinions favorables à
mettre en relation je pense que la
difficulté des manuels macron c'est que
les deux précédents présidents eux mêmes
visiblement avec des gros problèmes de
communication c'est à dire que nicolas
sarkozy au début a été extrêmement
populaire parce qu'il communiquait
beaucoup et qu'il avait désacralisé la
fonction présidentielle françois
hollande prétendait être un président
normal
et moi je me rappelle qu'au début de son
quinquennat macron sus suscite un
portrait d'emmanuel carrère
oui dit au fond moi j'aspire à être une
sorte de président anormal c'est à dire
qu'il assume le côté demi-dieu au fond
qui tient aux institutions de la vème
république et vous rappeler sa photo
officielle où il a soigneusement posé
quelques livres tout le monde après
s'interroge sur quels étaient ses livres
il ya deux téléphones portables
donc je sais pas si je parlerai de
théâtre au cra 6 août et atra lité
extrême mais en tout cas je pense qu'à
une mise en scène tellement permanente
qu'à un moment on aimerait que la pièce
de théâtre s'arrête et qu'on retrouve au
fond la fonction présidentielle donc je
pense qu'il a un problème avec ça après
je pense que le sujet c'est qu'il
théâtralis aussi sur des styles trop
différent c'est comme s'ils avaient
plusieurs mises en scène à la fois il ya
la métrologie vers trojans ya le
registre je trouve que le registre
intime les registres privée et est
extrêmement poussé personnellement il me
orange jeu ne contient pas je reste gêné
par le côté couple présidentiel c'est à
dire que je pense qu'on a élu un
président de la république et je pense
que je représente
je pense qu'elle joue très bien son rôle
mais qu'on l'appelle première dame
dérange et qu'elles soient tellement
présente en couple que les photos du
couple soit à ce point rendu public me
dérange
et puis en même temps il ya des choses
que j'aime bien moi je le dis par
exemple j'ai bien aimé l'entretien à la
nrf je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant sur le fait d'assumer une
part plus intellectuelles chez ce
président et en ce sens je comprends
pourquoi griveaux dit qu'il ya la
question du temps le temps long et je
pense qu'à trop de mélanges en fait il
ya il ya du lourd de la scène raconte
trois facettes route trop de concours
pour une hauteur vous allez tous les
communicants d'emmanuel macron si vous
voulez bien je suis assez gêné par ce
que je vois des bagnoles macron parce
que des bucs si c'est bon ils aiment pas
et n'aime pas beaucoup nous les gens
lille savoure avant l'élection il nous
avait bien après une action unie mais
plus à voulait plus me parler c'était
bon je suis président je les postures
présidentielle je trouve que ça a
complètement changé depuis quelques
temps et je pense qu'il y en train de
habib mais là la fonction de prison je
pense qu'il est en train d' abîmer son
image parce qu'ils qu'on disait yvon élu
s'il est un peu sur tous les fronts
qu'ils soient duo avec le petit
collégien il avait raison de le
redresser pour lui d rappelez moi
monsieur le président est pas manu je
pense que tous les prénoms confondues
aurait fait la même chose mais ses
photos à l'elysée nous prenions dingue
en prison il ne dit pas cela c'est comme
le livre sur françois hollande est en
train de continuer la soul dans le même
domaine où ils ont je suis l'an juif
only je suis branché et je suis sur
twitter je suis ce rôle et sur les
réseaux sociaux mais un président ne
devrait pas être très loin doit inciter
président parce que c'est ce que les
français attendent du président et en
particulier du président macron donc une
espèce de flou dans cette communication
qui me gêne et je pense qu'il a besoin
de redresser la situation
il n'a pas besoin de fès lost dont la
chose dont on a besoin c'est des
résultats et les résultats tardent à
venir et c'est ça qu'on attendait et on
vise haut parce que vous êtes maintenant
la seule à éventuellement pouvoir
il ya un fou dans la miga depuis il ya
un flou du coup sur le fond c'est à dire
qu'on a on parle beaucoup de l'image là
mais il ya aussi un flou sur le fond je
vais vous prendre un exemple qui est un
exemple un peu technique mais révélateur
il ya un débat en ce moment sur les
pensions de réversion qui sont ces
pensions qu on va s vous qu'on verse aux
veuves et aux veuves et aux regards des
cas de cancer ça concerne beaucoup de
gens pensent que la population c'est un
débat qui est mon qui monte et qui est
montée ces derniers jours
allait-on ou pas supprimer les pensions
de réversion là-dessus emmanuel macron
alors il a beau parler de temps long la
jambe rivaux là-dessus emmanuel macron
tweets en disant il n'est pas question
qu aucun retraités ne perde un seul
centime sur sa pension de réversion le
lendemain le même porte-parole du
gouvernement dit dans le cadre de la
réforme des retraites il y aura des
ajustements à la hausse et à la baisse
alors quand on se plonge dans plonge
dans la technique effectivement aucun
des deux n'a tort puisque les retraités
d'aujourd'hui comme le disait emmanuel
macron ne seront pas intimidés mais les
futures auront des modifications il ya
eu il ya quelques années je pense à la
période françois hollande on aurait
largement appeler ça un couac de
communication
donc cela on est plus indulgent
aujourd'hui pas sûr pas sûr que la
période d'apprentissage entre guillemets
ça fait un an qu'il est en apprentissage
en apprentissage a plutôt réussi le
président de la république
cette période est terminée là on arrive
bien passé on risque de ne plus laisser
passer ce genre de choix on est toujours
dans le wait and see me dont il est
rennes 1-2 j'en suis ravi d'y manu mâcon
vu quand même il perd des points ça
c'est sûr mais il est toujours 40% qu'il
quand même pas mal après une année à
l'elysée
mais là on est en train d'inciter un
espèce de tranquillisation trompe
ification de sa communication et je
pense réalisation que d'autres gens les
tweets les les phrases chocs pour
occuper le terrain tu faire le buzz pour
écraser pour y revenir en même temps il
vend par exemple ici on prend sncf la
réforme est faite
en tout cas elle est votée code du
travail s'est passé notre dame des
landes peu ou prou c'est réglé les
réformes lancker tout le monde s'en
satisfait ça pèse quoi la communication
mais la communication avait déjà traduit
comme étant des big bang successifs
s'étaient c'est le mot qui adoreraient
cadors encore la macro niveau or ces big
bang de bord ne sont pas vraiment les
vivants que ce sont des réformes
intéressantes naturellement mais ce sont
des réformes a minima pour le moins code
du travail réforme de sncf enfin bon
c'est très bien je ne dis pas cela mais
ça ne méritait pas ce niveau là et moi
je pense que plus on les dents l'enflure
plus on cache en fait un désarroi je
pense que là le maquereau nice mais
arrive au bout de ses contradictions et
sa contradiction initial était c'est ce
que j'expliquais dans ce livre que vous
avez bien voulu rappeler que le
diagnostic était faux ou départ c'est à
dire que le diagnostic de macron au
départ était bien qu'il y avait une
crise économique et sociale et c'est que
tout se règlerait avec ceux ci et qu'il
n'y avait pas de crise civilisationnelle
or ce qui éclate à la figure de tout le
monde et singulièrement à la sienne
c'est qu'il se rend compte qu'il n'est
plus dans le vent de l'histoire que le
vent de l'histoire s'écrit précisément
chez ceux qui l'avaient désigné comme
étant les affreux les épouvantables et
populiste les extrémistes c est que lui
même sous ses pieds se dérobe le sol
ainsi que d'ailleurs le angela merkel
entre pont entre les deux avec kiel où
il voulait former un couple qui aurait
insuffler la dynamique européenne lors
tous ceux ci s'effondre sous nos yeux et
donc je pense qu'il est dans une grande
panique et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ne
peut se se se masquer qu'à travers ces
signes successives ces symboles
successifs et encore une fois ces
symboles successifs sont faits pour pour
dissimuler de mon point de vue une
grande une panique parce que le fond est
en train de s'écrouler comme divin je
pense qu'ils l'ont serré a raison de
parler de l'europe et au fond de
l'international c'est à dire que à mon
avis il faut aussi regarder le comment
les autres regardent macron et moi ce
qui me frappe quand je voyage
au royaume uni en allemagne en italie
c'est quand même qu'il ya une sorte
d'admiration justement pour cette
communication d'emmanuel macron parce
que justement le monde s'effondre autour
de nous et je ne suis pas sûr que
emmanuel macron soit pleinement
conscient de cet effondrement je ne suis
pas sûr que le projet qui propose va
l'emporter mais en tout cas ils
suscitent ailleurs qu'en france une
forme d'admiration qu'il faut avoir
aussi en tête c'est à dire que par
exemple quand il va se confronter à
trump
quand il se confronte à trump lui même
les américains sont un peu ça trouve
qu'il est trop sympa mais quand il se
quand il va quand il va devant devant
les sénateurs quand il va devant devant
les devant les élus de la nation
américaine ya quelque chose qui se passe
donc moi je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui est en tout cas dans sa
communication internationale réussit
assez remarquablement bien après il a un
vrai sujet pour aborder les questions de
politique intérieure et au fond on est
face à quelqu'un qui a plus un projet
européen qui est plus à l'aise souvent
avec sookie ne relève pas de la france
que ce qui relève de la sernam en finale
ans qu'on l'attend à ces charmants est
extrêmement abstrait économique
il est à la fois théâtral est trop
philosophe est d'ailleurs le vocabulaire
qui l'utilisent moi j'aimerais qu'on
parle de son vocabulaire est un
vocabulaire extrêmement intellectuelle
extrêmement abstrait qui est pas du tout
un vocabulaire pour l'oignon doux
dingues
non mais ça ça s'appelle de la mise en
scène et quand on met très tôt et donc
parler de l'interview quand je parle des
discours sur mesure l'europe
au fond dans le pognon dedans moi ce que
je trouve c'est que quelque part on
dirait qu'il a tourné une espèce de
vidéos pour youtube qui est complètement
une manipulation c'est pas vraiment la
communication sur l'international
affiche internationale bon c'est très
bien il a une image
il est vrai qu'en jeu par la mise amis
britanniques ils sont tous nés
radioactifs dits manuels mâcon contre
l'occupant touiza mail par exemple un
premier ministre britannique qui
vraiment à l'agonie pour faire passer le
bric site
et il est vrai que l'élection du maniema
qu'on a donné 1
un bout il tenait long à l'europe par
rapport à l'époque de françois hollande
qui est en train de s'écrouler
aujourd'hui mais on sur le plan
international je suis désolé je pense
qu'il a une image qui était positive des
tracts il élit très sympathique avec les
autres dirigeants du monde mais il n'a
pas eu un succès avec dans l'autre choc
et n'a pas réussi à le faire changer
d'avis soso eu qu'un issue même si les
deux hommes en l'air de bien son temps
de ceux-ci par sosa va continuer avec
l'europe hélas pas réussi non plus très
bien avec la crise et millions il a fait
une énorme gaffe à mon avis on disons
que la france n'accepterait pas d'
installer un centre pour les migrants un
look bon c'est bien pour l'italie qui le
fasse même s'ils étaient l'italie ou la
grèce n'a pas envie c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelques couacs et ont une bonne image
mais les succès sur le plan
international comme est extrêmement
mince pour l'admettre je vous donne la
parole marie juste pour conclure mais
d'abord aussi quelques réactions gérard
nous dit c'est de l'esbrouffe la
communication et emmanuel macron anti
mac j'en ai assez de la com car ce n'est
que de la com il se contredit souvent
donc ils sont assez d'accord avec ce qui
se dit sur ce plateau
la question du jour qui vous est posée
sur lefigaro.fr emmanuel macron comique
communique-t-il trop vous êtes 69 % à
estimer que oui parmi ces instruments de
communication l'évaluation des ministres
marie visot soit fait partie depuis deux
jours on sait que faim depuis
aujourd'hui défilent devant un maquignon
ce pas l'elysée mais bon pour être notée
évalué pour qu'on leur donne le feu le
feuille de route pour l'année prochaine
ça aussi c'est un bon élément de
communication aussi parce qu'évidemment
c'est pas un entretien annuel comme nous
vous pouvons avoir dans une entreprise
avec des
c'est un bon entretien un bon élément de
communication
c'est aussi une manière pour emmanuel
macron de rappeler au cas où ils
auraient oublié que c'est lui le patron
notamment parce qu'il ya eu des couacs
et parce qu'il ya eu des ministres qui
se sont autorisés quelques sorties non
autorisées ces derniers temps que sa
firme on peut dire en un an
il n'y a pas eu de non majeurs de truc
et ça a laissé sur ces dernières
semaines s'est concentrée sur quelques
ministres sur ces dernières semaines ces
entretiens d'évaluation c'est un moyen
de stopper net de serrer un peu les
rangs et voilà attention ces maladies au
conseil des ministres il a été très très
ouvert sur ce sujet et bien d'un peu de
finalement de peu de compliments pour
cette comme je crois qu'on peut conclure
et dessus sur 7 n est pas de compliments
non plus sur celle de sarkozy ni des
hollande donc le sujet c'est la somme
président de la république comment
est-ce que ça communique
je pense que c'est une question ouverte
au delà des manuels macron le sujet se
voit comment un président de la
république qui a été hué en l'occurrence
avec macron par 20% d'un électorat peut
s'adresser à davantage qu'à 20% et donc
c'est qu'il a déjà une marge sa marge de
électorale était très étroite au départ
ses rangs son succès avait été construit
sur du sable
et l'on voit bien qu'à la moindre à la
au moindre problème ce sable
naturellement c'est cool ailleurs et
donc c'est à moi qu'il n'apprenne à
s'adresser à la france profonde
puisqu'il n'a pas l'air d'avoir de
vouloir comprendre moi je le vois mal
finir son quinquennat autrement que
dégringolant à nouveau dans les sondages
on parle avec sa fondation cinq
présidents république doit avoir avec
les réseaux sociaux ça aussi une intro
arrêté au monde dès lors on a
l'impression qu'ils apprennent toussaint
peur en marchant si lloris de distance
et la question de la rareté de la parole
et la majesté de cette posture qu'il
avait à mon avis c'était la bonne
intuition
oui on voit bien qu'il est en train de
la perdre de cette salle
son habitude de départ de dire je reste
silencieux jaurès éloigné je suis
jupiter il entre au pied de hollande
quoi c'était clair et vous connaissez le
proverbe
romain jupiter rend fou ce qu'il jubile
jupiter rend fou ce qu'ils veulent
limiter par l'enjeu les mêmes plus en
tête maintenant on va voir ça mais ça
revenait à ça en tout cas c'est pieter
jan sursis ne faut pas se précipiter
voilà ce que je voulais dire alors le
medef
à quoi sert le patron le jupiter du
medef c'est donc geoffroy roux de
bézieux depuis ce matin il a été élu
avec plus de 55% des voix une élection à
suspense une compétition acharnée
jusqu'au bout de candidats et de styles
tout ça on l'a vu
geoffroy roux de bézieux il est donc
patron des patrons mais la question
reste ouverte le medef
aujourd'hui ça sert à quoi réponse dans
un instant mais on écoute d'abord le
nouveau président c'était ce matin juste
après l'élection
le message est clair le medef doit
changer et donc le premier signal 50% de
deux femmes il est important parce que
c'est celui que la presse fars va
retenir on doit évoluer
nous devons développer notre
organisation doit évoluer en phase avec
la société
alors on a entendu le geoffroy roux de
bézieux sur recense les femmes or il est
un discours déjà mais j'aurais revenir
sur la place du medef est ce que
finalement le emmanuel macron on en
revient à la communication des nappes a
un peu tué le job de président du medef
en leur coupant l'herbe sous le pied sur
beaucoup de sujets alors
effectivement la relation qu'il a avec
les partenaires sociaux dans leur
ensemble que ce soit patronat aux
syndicats
ça a été compliqué dès le départ c'est à
dire qu'il quand même il a très
clairement décidé de se passer des les
corps intermédiaires et du medef encore
plus parce qu'effectivement il leur a
coupé la ressource ou pied avec des
sujets qui tenait à coeur aux chefs
d'entreprise c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs les deux candidats pour la
campagne du medef ont fait construire
leur discours sur on l'a entendu un
geoffroy roux de bézieux dire il faut
qu'on réforme le medef il faut qu'on se
transforme qu'on change je sais pas
uniquement une histoire de femmes 1 et
10 les médias vont retenir les femmes
mais mais c'est plus qu'une histoire de
femme c'est je vais vous révéler les
résultats d'un baromètre viavoice hec le
figaro publie demain donc intacte
embargo figaro économie je voulais juste
vous dire que sur les décideurs qui ont
été interrogées pour ce baromètre les
trois quarts veulent un medef qui
s'engagent et propose alors que un tout
petit 10% 9 veulent un medef qui
s'opposent c'est à dire que le lobbying
l'ancien traîner dans les couloirs de
bercy et l'élysée matignon pour essayer
de dire mais non ça c'est pas bien
présent ça c'est fini ce medef là c'est
fini les chefs d'entreprise veulent
autre chose veulent être constructif
proactif re réfléchir se mettre à
réfléchir pour avoir des propositions il
ya des tas d'enjeu pour les entreprises
dans les prochaines années
fiscalité
harmonisation européenne retraite
retraite ils ne veulent plus être dans
le lobbying défensive m force de
proposition la finalité du medef
les chutes moi je crois qu'il faut
rappeler que beaucoup d'entrepreneurs ne
sont pas au medef c'est à dire que la
représentativité du medef est un vrai
sujet aujourd'hui sur je crois deux
millions d'adhérents potentiels ils sont
123 mille verront en fait on on tacle
souvent les syndicats en france dans les
années très très très faible
représentativité on ne dit pas assez que
le medef a une très faible
représentativité aussi et ça il faut le
dire et notamment chez les startups
heures dans le secteur des services
alors la rue baisieux c'est un ans il
dit qu'il est un serial entrepreneur que
il vient du secteur des services c'est
une très belle vitrine c'est une très
belle communication justement après la
question c'est est-ce que ça va inciter
justement ces entrepreneurs la adhéré au
medef sûrement s'il propose quelque
chose
autre chose que son cv qui est
remarquable son parcours tout ce qu'on
veut et mais il ya il ya quelque chose
autour d'eux à quoi sert le medef vous
l'avez vous avez très bien poser la
question pas seulement parce qu'elle
manuel macro mais aussi parce que
l'esprit d'entreprise l'esprit
d'initiative aujourd'hui il n'est pas au
medef on fait il est ailleurs il est
dans une forme d'aller-retour on sait
entre le salariat et l'entreprise c'est
ça aussi une des interrogations qu'on a
autour de la question du travail est
aussi l'interrogation sur l'entreprise
citoyenne je voyais que roux de bézieux
dit bon ma morale sociale c'est pas trop
mon truc par rapport à son concurrent
son ex-concurrent toute la question du
rôle des salariés toute la question de s
que l'entreprise peut au fond apporter
des réponses qui sont aujourd'hui plus
redonné par l'état c'est des questions
passionnantes sur lesquels il ya des
vraies recherches et on a l'impression
que quelque part presque le cette
victoire d'un roux de bézieux jean
l'entrepreneur sportifs bien dans ses
baskets qui assume d'être libéral c'est
presque date et par rapport à toutes les
interrogations sur la reprise du 21e
siècle alors pour en parler avant de
vous écouter
yvan et philippe gendret qu'on écoute
l'éditorialiste économique d'rtl
françois lenglet ce matin il citait les
propos c'est assez intéressant du
fondateur d'alstom c'est un monsieur
auguste detoeuf et c'était en 1936 en
l'écoutant
il faut que le peuple ait confiance en
nous il faut il faut que qu'il croit que
nous poursuivions uniquement l'intérêt
public
il ne le croira que si nous le croyons
nous mêmes il faut que nous pensions
tous comme si nous étions le peuple mais
si tout cela nous paraît vain impossible
est surhumain si nous refusons les
forêts le sacrifice si nous les jugeons
stérile et dangereux
soyez assurés que d'autres sans doute
plus jeunes que nous moins déformée par
un long passé entreront dans la voie que
nous n'aurons pas ouverte
et parce qu'ils ont l'âme fresh et le
coeur pur recréeront sans nous et malgré
nous à travers la justice et la misère
le monde que nous aurons laisser mourir
il faut replacer dans son contexte en
1936 mais sûre pour pour essayer de
comprendre un peu ce que peut être
effectivement la finalité du medef et le
ce que disait le ciel et marine
on se demande aujourd'hui parfois si
c'est réellement
6 à sa place dans la démocratie moderne
patronales à partir avec ce que ce qui a
été dit il ne sert à rien pour l'instant
c'est vrai il n'y a jamais participé aux
débats d'idées pour reprendre un terme
que les journalistes aiment bien et dans
le fond le débat d'idées le port puisque
maintenant 43 % des jeunes français se
reconnaissent dans une dynamique de
créateurs d'entreprise qui n'était pas
le cas il ya encore quelques années où
chaque poule
la majorité des jeunes français
voulaient de fonctionnaires donc il ya
eu déjà quand même une révolte mentalité
une révolution dans les mentalités qui
normalement devrait faire écho à ce que
un message que pourrait porter le medef
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant le
medef qui d'abord qui écoute le medef
ball medvedev ne m'a jamais vraiment
intéressé dans les propositions qu'il a
eu en effet c'était un lobby qui étaient
là pour des formes d un corporatisme
mais je pense qu'il ya en effet des
questions qui se posent nos bords
singulièrement la question de l'accès à
l'égalité dans les entreprises qui est
une question qui n'est pas résolu qui va
se poser de plus en plus peut-être même
de réfléchir à marier le un
protectionnisme et le libéralisme il y a
là aussi d'aider à une question qui se
pose de plus en plus ardemment la
question sociale dans les faits la
question de la de l'entrepôt de l'accès
à la sociabilité je ne sais pas quel est
le terme exact qui est dans qui est
employé le l'ouverture sociale de
l'entreprise le rôle social de
l'entreprise est une question
passionnante
comment l'entreprise peut peut en
elle-même faire cohésion et effet record
par rapport à des des personnels par
rapport à une société qui s'éclate
donc là dessus il y à des sujets de
réflexion qui sont passionnants à mener
maintenant je ne suis pas un spécialiste
lebedev est en retard pour cet enfant
tant que spectateur et les observateurs
gm a été le medef sortent en effet de
ces sentiers battus et à explorer ces
sujets là j'ai dit que le medef
souffre d'un déficit de connaissances en
france que les jaunes et beaucoup de
gens qui sapent notre axe agge liste
quoi ça c'est qu'est ce que c'est ah bon
qu'est-ce que c'est le medef je ne
savais même pas ça existe et ça c'est
l'un des grands défis de ce nouveau
disque en fin des années 90 non marie le
changement cnps medef alors qu'il est
entré maintenant dans les têtes mais est
il a quand même un autre défi vous
l'avez évoqué c'est le fait qu'elles
sont vingt-trois mille entreprises
qu'ils soient affiliés au medef sur les
deux millions qui existent en france
c'est un peu comme la cgt qui cherchent
à exister comme le medef donc ils sont
un peu même s'ils sont aux antipodes
dans leur façon de marcher ils sont un
peu dans la même situation il faut il
faut il la survie du medef contre c'est
manon ce monde
entrepreneur est elle qui change
extrêmement rapidement et justes bons
sites simples confronté en angleterre
c'est la même chose pour le aussi bien
et qui la confédération de l'industrie
britannique qui a que 190 mille
adhérents sur les 2 millions ou plus
d'entreprises britanniques donc c'est
vrai que c'est une une autre une
situation difficile et le troisième défi
qu'il a c'est de fait oublier cette
image qui pouvait la vie du medef que le
medef existe que pour les grandes
entreprises pour les grandes groupes qui
sont qu'il soutient les les
multinationales mais pas le petit
entrepreneur français qui n'a rien à
voir que le medef parce que le medef
n'est pas là pour lui et là c'est quand
même un gros défi pour ceux ne veut dire
cette image le medef c'est paris le
cac40 est pas la pme de province
oui ça c'est vrai est par ailleurs moi
je voulais réagir par rapport à emmanuel
macron et le fait qu'on dise au fond n'a
pas besoin d'un medef parce qu emmanuel
macron fait le job pour les entreprises
moi je trouve qu'il ya quand même un
étrange mélange cgmpe emmanuel macron il
est aussi très étatiste
il a un langage qui n'est certainement
pas celui qui venait pas forcément
compréhensible pour tous et moi je crois
qu'il est il est nécessaire vraiment
qu'il ya une représentation des
entreprises qui reprennent plus tôt du
poil de la bête parce que je pense que
emmanuel macron comme son gouvernement
pense l'entreprise quand même avec une
culture qui n'est pas celle de
l'entreprise quelque part le plus
entrepreneuriale c'est jean michel
blanquer
c'est à dire que au fond ce qui veut
faire à l'éducation nationale ça c'est
assez compréhensible pour tous
il ya une histoire d'évaluation de mise
en responsabilité
en face et c'est quelque chose qui est
assez entrepreneuriale après les
entretiens d'évaluation pour les
ministres une manière de dire je suis le
patron hockey mais enfin l'entreprise
france c'est pas c'est pas les
entrepreneurs et je trouve que cette
question de l'esprit d'initiative et
comment est il apparaît chez les jeunes
toute cette question qui au fond ne
dépend pas de la forme juridique de
l'entreprise mais qui montre un
changement de société ça emmanuel macron
moi je trouve qu'il ne l'incarnent pas
je trouve qu'il est trop autoritaire
pour incarner ça quand on est
entrepreneuriale quand on a l'esprit
initiatives ont construit du collectif
on ne souhaite pas de la hiérarchie et
je pense que là il ya quelque chose qui
au fond est contradictoire
quelques éléments de réponse aussi chez
nos internautes gérard nous disent c'est
de l'esbroufé nan ça c'était sur la
cover donc je comprend des noms
peut-être mais pas non selon lui c'était
c'était sur le sujet président l'eau le
medef ne sert qu'à macro et aux 4 40 ans
t-mac le medef représente bien les
grosses entreprises pour les plus
petites j'en suis moins sûr
et la question qu'on vous posez sur
twitter le medef représente t-il bien le
patronat vous êtes non vous êtes
répondait non à 69 % mais je pense a
réussi son un point c'est qu'il a fait
accepter depuis son existence
le fait que l'économie de marché et
quelque chose qui marche bien en france
avec même même il a convaincu à belmont
la droite n'était pas en convaincre mais
il a convaincu la gauche et même
l'extrême gauche que c'est un système
qui a raison d'être en france
alors qu'avant le medef je pense qu'il y
avait une grande différence entre ce
qu'il a accepté l'économie de marché ce
qui ne voulait absolument pas et c'est
globalement accepté maintenant je pense
que le medef est pour beaucoup dans
cette ville
c'est marrant on dénature un peu le ce
qu'est le libéralisme il se prétend
comme étant en effet un libéral vais
d'abord il est c'est un banquier c'est
un énarque qui s'est d'abord
technocrates il n'est pas libérale il
n'a pas la culture libérale même s'il a
un discours apparemment libérables et il
n'est pas libéré parce qu'il n'a pas il
n'a pas réformé la france dans le sens
du d'un pays libéral qu'il ne désendette
par la france il
il ne rétrécit pas le périmètre de
l'état et il n'a pas rêvé mais vous
l'avez dit un pool avait dit également
il n'a pas ce raisonnement peut avoir un
chef d'entreprise de vouloir être
rationnel et du devoir être efficace
alors il a bien il a il a l'air et le
soleil la ilaha illallah musique n'a pas
les paroles à grands pas libéral
marie juste un tout petit peu je crois
pas que ce soit le média fille convaincu
la gauche de plongée est globalement
accepté maintenant je pense que le medef
est pour quelque chose dans cette
acceptation il y à aussi qu' il se
passait des choses chez nos voisins et
que la gauche a bien vu ce qui se
passait partout en europe
globalisation et puis à l'époque
françois hollande il avait dans son
entourage
chef d'entreprise s'appelait louis
gallois qui lui avait rendu dès les
premières semaines du quinquennat un
rapport sur les entreprises la
compétitivité la croissance que ça crée
l'emploi et que qui a fait un travail à
mon avis bien combien ou plus important
que de choses mais à gauche et droite
puisque aujourd'hui macro à gagner sur
ni gauche ni droite c est que
ressurgissent les catégories comme avec
une certaine force c'est que l'électorat
de gauche qui a voté pour mac rond comme
l'électorat de gauche qui avaient voté
pour françois hollande continue à
ressentir les choses comme une forme de
trahison c'est à dire que peut-être que
effectivement ça a convaincu je crois
que c'est plutôt schröder où blair qui
ont pu convaincre au fond les
socialistes français de ce qu'il fallait
faire mais en tout cas l'électorat de
gauche il est pas convaincu donc il ya
quelque chose sur comment est-ce qu'on
regagne les élections qui reste posée on
ne va pas ouvrir ce débat on va plutôt
parler du pouce des policiers c'est vous
voyez bien alors c'est un rapport
sénatorial qui en dit long sur le
malaise des forces de l'ordre six mois
dans quête d'une commission sénatoriale
dans le figaro laurent largement contre
ce matin les mots mx connu ressortent
manque de moyens épuisement des troupes
qui peuvent parfois travailler jusqu'à
cinq week-ends sur 6 par mois
démoralisation avec un taux de suicide
supérieur à la moyenne nationale de 36%
mais le rapporteur de cette commission
sénatoriale
c'est une qui s'appelle françois
grosdidier les sénateurs aient l'air
pointe un autre problème c'est celui de
la justice qui pour faire court mais
trop souvent dehors les délinquants que
la police vient d'arrêter c'est un peu
son point de vue on l'écoutent c'était
ce matin dans les décrypteurs sur figaro
lights ils ont le sentiment d'être
traités plus durement que certains
délinquants alors c'est peut-être un
sentiment excessif
c'est évident qu'il n'ya pas la réponse
pénale adaptée
c'est à dire qu'ils ont ils prennent
beaucoup de risques pour arrêter et
mettre à disposition de la justice des
individus qui parfois sont libérés plus
vite que aller ça leur pose le problème
du sens de leur action et celui de la
reconnaissance des 6,8 c'est de la faute
de la justice si la police ne tourne pas
rond
donc bien sûr que non et mais en tout
cas cette question des moyens est cette
question de la procédure et de la
bureaucratisation ça c'est un vrai sujet
pour les policiers c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui mais sur la question
quand même qui était là que les jumeaux
plusieurs sur la question des noms enfin
moi je ne pense pas et je suis étonné
pour être franche de voir un élu de la
république qui relaie comme ça au fond
ce que disent les syndicats de police je
pense qu'un aspect assez démagogique
dans ce qui vient de dire après qu'ils
aient un vrai problème sur l'adaptation
de la procédure par rapport à la réalité
de certains crimes et délits sur le
terrain ça c'est un sujet c'était
l'exemple par exemple pour un vol à
l'étalagé on y consacre une heure en
temps
uttenheim moyenne évidemment il ya
quarante-cinq minutes de procédure non
il ya il ya un sujet sur la
bureaucratisation et sur la question de
la procédure après et la question des
moyens moi je me rappelle des émeutes de
2005 à l'époque j'avais fait une mission
auprès du ministère la justice est en
fait ce qu'on voyait c'est par exemple
la justice qui est moins bien traités
que la police a il faut avoir ça aussi
en tête puisque la france est un des
derniers pays de l'union européenne en
termes de moyens sur les budgets les
jeux je n'avais pas d'ordinateur il y
avait une mise en commun des données etc
on voit qu'aujourd'hui avec l'épuisement
des finances publiques
au fond ça rattrape et aussi la police
puisque ce qui est dit - roche plus
marqué par le fait de dire que par
exemple les voitures ne fonctionne pas
que les policiers passent leur temps
dans leur commissariat qui sont
extrêmement vétus alors que moi je pense
que les policiers devraient sortir être
au contact de la population parce que
quelque part il ya aussi une sorte de
suspicion parfois sur les tâches
concrètes que doivent faire les
policiers et leur présence ou leur
absence
donc là je crois qu'il ya un malaise qui
est grandissant sur la procédure
alisation le manque de moyens mais que
ce soit de la faute des juges
moi je pense qu'il connaît de logis à
dire que je comptais jugé qu'un sénateur
en train de dire ça sam ça me choque
profondément
il vend de cette question précise c'est
une vieille affaire à cette histoire de
juges laxistes ou j'entends ça appuie
maintenant 30 ans est donc bon cela
existe peut-être bien que je trouve que
la justice maintenant de semble être
moins laxiste qu'elle ne l'a été mais
enfin s'il si les policiers l'odyssée
quinon qui vient il ya un fond de vérité
bien sûr merci aux magistrats répondent
généralement oui mais les procédures
sont mal ficelés
mais moi je ne pense pas c'est ce que
pense que le fond du problème soit
celui-là ou en tout cas ce n'est pas
simplement celui là que c'est celui là
on le connaît depuis maintenant des
lustres
je crois qu'aujourd'hui s'il ya un
problème enfin tel que je le vois mais
je n'ai pas vu assez apparaître
clairement dans l'en dans l'anc est tel
que je le comprends le malaise de la
police et de la gendarmerie c'est que et
les policiers les gendarmes sont laissés
aujourd'hui en première ligne face à ce
que l'on appelle la contre-société 7
contre société qui est celle qui s'est
constituée dans les banlieues qui
refusent les règles de la république qui
les refusent avec violence et qui donc à
ça il l'est les forces de l'ordre les
voies parfois comme des forces
d'occupation en terre étrangère celle ci
c'est ceci ce qui se passe aussi et ce
que voit ce que disent les policiers
pour ceux que je rencontre
c'est qu'ils ne se sentent pas soutenus
par leur propre hiérarchie et encore
moins par le président de la république
souvenez-vous de françois hollande
allant au chevet du jeune théo
qui avait été soi-disant violées par des
policiers s'étaient aperçus en fait que
cette affaire était fausse le jeune le
jeune théo ne s'était pas fait violer
par un policier en tout cas patiemment
ils n'avaient pas volontairement etc
enfin bon cette enquête là ceci a été
démontré à moi que vous même annonciez
qu'il ya encore un rebondissement mais
enfin pour moi cette affaire était clair
et en revanche quand vous avez eu des
drames comme à manier en ville etc
ces boues des policiers brûlés dans des
voitures ce couple de policiers qui a
été égorgé dans sa maison que vous ne
voyez pas la même sollicitude des
pouvoirs publics et donc je sais cette
grande frustration c'est cette grande
colère des forces de l'ordre un peu
moins de la gendarmerie qui est plus qu
est une force armée qui c'est qui se
ressaisit davantage peut-être qui sait
maîtriser davantage les sentiments mais
moi je comprend d'abord parfaitement que
les policiers puissent se sentir à ce
point désespérée et je pense que c'est
davantage à mettre en perspective avec
en effet cette cette fracture cette
fracture territoriale qui advient et que
ne veut pas sur laquelle ne veut pas se
confrontent ne veulent pas se confronter
les bois est effectivement la police mal
aimé voir prise pour cible parce que
portant l'uniforme les 1 3 il ya trois
choses la première c'est qu'en parlant d
des juges
je pense que c'est on se trompe de cible
en tapant sur les lieux via nos
problèmes si c'est que les prisons en
france
complètement plein et des baux de
personnes
tout le monde en prison donc il faut
quand même je comprends que les
policiers risquent leur vie passe
beaucoup de temps sur le terrain arrêter
les suspects parfois des gens dangereux
et se sont démunis quand ils voient ces
suspects qui sont relâchés assez
rapidement c'est tout à fait
compréhensible mais je ne pense pas que
c'est uniquement la faute des jeux que
j'ai un non sens où les grandes malaise
en france et c'est un gros travail qu'il
faut entreprendre
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
je comprends tout à fait que les
policiers soient
frustré et en colère contre les moyens
qui sont mises à disposition pour la
quittes histoire hier soir ça tombe bien
je roulais en voiture dans l'oise je
vois passer devant moi rond point info
de police et je vois vieille renault qui
passe devant mes yeux bleus avec les
lettres de police décoller sur le côté
non non il est pas davantage mais je
dise ça toi sinon c'est un fourgon de
police
comme on voit les anciens camionnette de
la poste qui sont revendus à d'autres
personnes et à bord il y avait 4 ans
dorment
ce faux bond mais c'était une honte pour
la police et jeté même pas en train de
lire le rapport aux que j'ai vu mais
même je disais mais je n'aimerais pas
être policier dans un faux bond comme ça
parce qu'ils passent aux qui va pas
tomber en panne on arrivait au poste de
police
ça c'est évidemment une grande
frustation qu'on n'a pas les moyens
nécessaires pour lutter contre ces
sociétés qui est en évolution constante
les banlieues où parfois la police n'ose
même pas aller parce que c'est des zones
de non-droit et maintenant une nouvelle
phénomène non pas seulement fausse mais
un peu partout en europe où on on
attaque la police n'ont pas seulement
parce qu'on se sent attaqué mais on
attaque la police parce qu'on a envie
d'attaquer policiers ont envie de le
tuer et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
un phénomène relativement récent est le
troisième chose je suis d'accord avec ce
que dit ils vont c'est le fait que je
pense que la police ne sont pas
soutenues par l'iran chiite
et ça c'est quand même très démotivant
pour les policiers et on comprend qu'il
ya aussi une augmentation du nombre de
suicides parmi les policiers qui quand
même dramatique la police pas soutenu
par sa mère chez qui manque de moyens
les moyens supplémentaires une meilleure
gestion la révision puisque c'était le
thème le thème
de votre lancement moi je me mets à la
place du policier qui a dix jours allume
ta radio et en tant qu' en l'absence
d'un juge disponible parce qu'on n'a pas
trouvé quelqu'un pour remplacer la
magistrate qui était malade
sept trafiquants présumés ont été
libérés en liberté ces traits c'est très
très bas taux mais mais finalement c'est
ça aussi le blues quotidien du policier
je m'en sortais là je relisais un
sondage qui est fait par un syndicat de
de la police nationale donc à prendre
comme tel mais 80% des policiers
estiment leur travail discréditer parce
que les délinquants sont remis trop
rapidement on dirait quand même cette
question sont donc du coup il ne le voit
pas comme comme je dirais pas un allié
mais mais la justice tu n'es pas
n'est pas un partenaire voilà deux de la
police juste je donne la réponse parce
que ça rejoint ce que dit marie la
question que vous posez 6 sur twitter
selon vous les blues des policiers et
gendarmes était la faute de la justice
là vous êtes 77% à dire oui c'est assez
massif quand même jacques ça c'est les
policiers les policiers sont ne sont pas
pris au sérieux et la justice est
laxiste commentaires de jacques qui
poursuit les policiers ne sont pas oui
c'est le même et la justice est
clairement laxiste à [ __ ] ils
voudraient qu'on aille assez vite sur ce
thème un mot pour conclure yvan parce
que ça qu'on garde un peu de à cela se
rajoute également quand même une
mobilisation politique contre la police
qui est monté par l'extrême gauche elle
même quand vous allez dans les
manifestations ce que je fais
régulièrement de l'extrême gauche pour
retaper le rassure et noah pour retarder
certains il est courant d'ivoire des
panneaux on déteste la police j'aime le
jem le poulet grillé et ses 68 avait
déjà oui mais non cela cela légitime des
passages à l'acte violents contre les
forces de l'ordre c'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya quelques années quand une
voiture de police avait été mise est
mise à feu par part n'ont pas le même
pas des black blocks mais parler les
p'tits lundi l'enfant berne à nouveau on
passe à notre quatrième tél le cil parce
qu'on n'aura pas le temps d'en parler
c'est passionnant c'est cette crise de
la masculinité ce nouveau phénomène qui
traverse l'occident c'était le titre
d'un des articles les plus lus ces
derniers jours sur le fil le site du
figaro lefigaro.fr un intérêt doc
extrême pour ce papier signé eugénie
bastié qui fait qui a fait le tour des
études universitaires sur le sujet dans
découvre donc il ya des études et des
thèses autour de cette question centrale
finalement le mal on peut ajouter blanc
est-il une espèce menacée avant d'en
discuter je vous propose de regarder cet
échange assez surréaliste entre la
ministre
marlène schiappa ministre de l'égalité
homme-femme et l'acteur belge
jean-claude van damme c'était samedi
lors de l'émission on n'est pas couché
très souvent quand on marche dans la rue
eh ben on aimerait ne pas se dire tiens
je suis une femme et on a parfois une
insulte une invective quelqu'un qui nous
suit et qui nous rappelle qu'on est une
femme et à la condition qui est
inégalitaire
par rapport à celle de la excusez moi
mais je vous en prie si tu as envie de
faire quelque chose tu suis ton
mouvement à toi et n'impose pas sur
d'autres femmes ce que tous voudraient
toi faire tu comprends il faut respect
c'est que la vie et voilà mais c'est
vrai alors on fait ce que vous venez de
sa super sat elle vient de calculer les
dab est alors son nom en anglais ça
s'appelle aussi du mels planning c'est à
dire quand un homme interrompt une femme
pour lui expliquer qu'il sait mieux
qu'elle des chaussures sont propres ça
vous parle je suis vivant et cet échange
jean claude van damme de cette lancée
dans sa voix on sait le galeb faut
savoir arrêter les guerres comme les
grèves et en l'occurrence la guerre des
sexes la guerre des sexes elle a été
gagnée par par les femmes
maintenant c'est une évidence il suffit
de voir comment il lui même prend une
raclée se fait applaudir par tout le
monde alors qu'il dit une une réflexion
qui pourrait être au niveau malgré tout
et donc je crois qu'on va trop loin pour
aller pour aller vite on va trop loin
quand même dans cette dans cette guerre
des sexes dans cette stigmatisation du
mal du mâle blanc et je fonds il faut
faire attention au retour de bâton et le
retour de bâton je le voit déjà
apparaître aux états unis où le
mouvement est apparue le mouvement
féministe est apparu dans tous ses
exploits
dansez dansez légitimité puis dans ses
excès il apparaît aujourd'hui avec la
survenue de donald trump qui est
vraiment le lentilles alors qu'ils ne
représentent pas en effet le mâle tels
que je veux le tel que je le voudrais
bien vous concevoir reprendre un peu de
pouvoir si je puis dire mais qui est
significatif de cette de cette réaction
d'une partie de la société américaine
face à ces excès d'une société
vénusienne donc je pense que c'est mars
est en train de gagner sur vénus en tout
cas dans la peau en politique
internationale un peu partout et il ya
d'ailleurs y compris en europe vous
voyez que les gouvernements qui
s'affiche aujourd'hui sont des
gouvernements autoritaires mars plutôt
que vénusien l'europe etc
la france est donc c'est un ca donne un
élément de lecture de ce qui risque de
se passer c'est dire que l'histoire est
toujours un éternel balancier et je
pense que le ballon s'est fait de
revenir et peut-être pour enfin nous
réhabiliter nous nous les nous les mâles
c'est bien dit jarque pour dire stop à
la guerre des sexes lucile moi je ne
ressens pas du tout de guerre des sexes
mais en fait je trouve qu'en revanche à
l'occupant beaucoup les médias je trouve
que le phénomène mis tous les réseaux
sociaux je pense que toute façon les
réseaux sociaux créent des guerres il ya
quand même des guerre virtuelle les
guerres extrêmement forte qui tiennent
aussi aux instruments avec lesquels on
les mène après sur la question de croix
que le sujet c'est égalité différence
moi j'avais je me rappelle d'avoir à
réfléchir là dessus il ya quelques
années
dire qu'on demande l'égalité des droits
mais il ya des différences dans les vie
qu'on mène et c'est peut-être je trouve
que jean claude van damme il est
absolument odieux mais il a voulu dire
un truc qui était au fond on mène sa
barque bon et c'était odieux la façon de
la forme mais au fond on voit bien qu'il
ya un débat forme contenu j'ai quand
même un débat très profond et tient aux
réseaux sociaux également je pense que
la question de la place des hommes
allaient poser depuis la révolution
française il ya des études historiques
qui disent au fond depuis 1789 les
hommes ne cessent de vivre une
transformation de leur rôle les femmes
ont progressivement acquis le droit de
vote elles ont acquis des droits
économiques et ça n'a pas supprimé la
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes
et maintenant il ya ce sujet sur la
question sexuelle je pense que le corps
des femmes reste quelque chose de ces au
fond c'est ce que disait la ministre au
fond elle disait mon corps contre quand
je suis dans la rue je me fais agresser
à cause de mon corps etc
on pourra toujours disserter sur la
question de l'égalité de la différence
mais la question du corps et du de la
force du corps féminin comme symbole
sexuel restera un sujet est là dessus
oui je crois qu'il y aura toujours des
éléments de pouvoir ce qui s'est passé
avec strauss kahn ce qui s'est passé
avec harvey weinstein
voilà donc ça c'est des choses qui à mon
avis ne vont pas être supprimée parce
que on peut toujours faire du droit on
peut toujours recherché l'égalité mais
il y aura toujours une différence sur la
portée face sur le chiot sur la question
sexuelle est ce que c'est une guerre je
ne sais pas je crois qu'il ya un enjeu
de pouvoir dans l'arctique génie bastia
consacré à cette question elle disait
ses hommes ont perdu le contrôle de la
procréation c'est pour prolonger
prolonger ce que dit lucile donc ils ont
perdu le contrôle la procréation
quand ils sont jeunes élèves à l'école
sont pas les meilleurs généralement ils
se font dépasser par les filles et la
force physique dans notre monde moderne
ne sert plus à grand chose
et ben oui quand j'étais gamin je
regardais les émissions de télévision en
grande-bretagne que je revois maintenant
sur youtube
je trouve que quand même la femme était
très mal traités et ont rien là-dessus à
l'époque donc la société a quand même et
nous aimons changé depuis 30 40 ans et
je ne sais pas c'est yvon ouzou nous
avez fait des reportages sur la
condition féminine au fond on est
réalisé pas mal surtout sur le fait que
les femmes n'étaient pas représentés
représenté comme il fallait sur les
conseils d'administration croit il ait
pas plus de femmes ministres parce qu'il
y avait ces cris d'hommes qui élisent
est désormais ce qu'ils veulent ils pas
des femmes parce qu'ils pensaient que
les femmes allaient partie et fait des
bébés etc
bon si ça peut changer la société je
suis le premier est d'accord alors pour
tous ces hommes qui ont prom avec les
femmes qui trouvent que il ya le retard
à simon très anti homme et donc la
masculinité et est en question
eh bien je connais un très bon psy qui
peut les recevoir je trouve que c'est
quand même un peu dommage
j'ai un médecin femme j'ai une coiffeuse
femme j'ai une dentiste femme mama
directrice est une femme
map et dj est une femme je n'ai pas de
problème avec cela
quand on dans les cordes du journalisme
puis dans la sorbonne j'ai 18 filles et
quatre garçons
je vis ma vie très bien en tant qu homme
dans ses émissions disposition les faits
remontent au fort la macif c'était les
femmes battez vous pour avoir une bonne
place et maintenant les hommes passent
et vous faut avoir une bonne place si
vous êtes le meilleur vous avez réussi
vous allez avoir la place
ne soyez pas intimider par les femmes
qui vont payer votre place elle
rompt pas est-ce que l'évolution de la
société doit se traduire à une crise de
la masculinité obligatoirement m'a juste
moi je suis contente de votre plaidoyer
enfin c'est est ce que c'est les hommes
doivent être en crise parce que on
essaye de rattraper les salaires on
essaye de faire je parle de jeu que je
connais un peu plus le monde de
l'entreprise de monde économique est
quand même y compris par des lois on est
passés par des lois pour essayer de
rattraper tout ça est ce que forcément
ça doit se traduire par une crise de la
masculinité est ce que j'avais appareils
ressorti quelques petits chiffres en 90
1997 le taux d'emploi des hommes était
de 82% il a baissé à 76 pour cent dix
ans plus tard alors que le mouvement
s'est fait de l inverse pour les femmes
66 % 97 69 % dix ans plus tard
est-ce que ça doit se traduire par une
crise de la masculinité enfin à chaque
fois je moi je
je me pose la même question et parce que
je suis moi je suis un petit peu comme
vous j'ai pas l'impression de voir
autour de moi alors finalement le style
qui a été mais c'est parce que je pense
qu'il ya quand même un champ dans lequel
ça résiste fortement et où les femmes
n'arrivent pas à faire leur place c'est
quand même le champ politique c'est à
dire que par exemple ce que disait ivan
est tout à fait juste sur la le retour
d'un certain pouvoir autoritaire il ya
erdogan en turquie il ya poutine ya
trump emmanuel macron nom s'est passé
nière douane ni trump mais enfin c'est
quand même un jeune homme autoritaire je
crois qu'on peut dire quelque chose de
cet ordre là et donc il ya quelque chose
et moi je me rappelle quand on a voté la
loi sur la parité en france donc en
disant qu'il fallait qui au fond
l'objectif était qui et autant de femmes
élues que d'hommes élus bon c'était au
début des années 2000 et il a fallu
attendre les élections de l'année
dernière pour que les choses commencent
vraiment à se faire donc il ya quelque
chose sur aussi la façon dont est un
décalage entre le droit et la réalité de
l'évolution de la société
dans ce domaine là il ya des éléments
psychanalytique
ça a été dit il ya des éléments de
culture familiale personnelle etc
après tout la question c'est aussi
comment est-ce que soit comme femme
comme personne on a envie d'être heureux
comme
ce que nous a dit phillips et chacun a
droit à une forme de différents ce qui
tient de sa personnalité et on n'est pas
réductible à son sexe moi c'est quelque
chose que je voudrais dire assez
fortement aussi là dessus parce que
peut-être en vieillissant on s'affirme
davantage aussi comme personne que comme
femmes comme hommes ou alors peut-être
se séparent vieillissant mais il faut
garder cette espèce de variables et je
trouve que trop souvent le débat en tout
cas médiatique est réduit à ça ça sera
le mot de la fin je vous propose qu'on
se quitte sur quelques images on en
parlait justement le début de l'émission
vous aviez envie de les voir ces images
c'est celle de ses enfants thaïlandais
qui ont été retrouvés sains et saufs au
fin fond du la grotte du gouffre où ils
sont coincés depuis maintenant une
dizaine de jours on a donc appris hier
soir qu'ils étaient vivants ils sont une
sont 13 avec leurs moniteurs etc
viennent de passer quand même une
dizaine de jours sans vivres et là on
sait qu'ils sont vivants mais on sait
pas encore très bien quand on voit les
extraire de là ce sont les premières
images qui nous sont parvenus merci
encore à tous les quatre merci à tous
ceux qui ont préparé cette émission et
on se retrouve demain pour un nouveau
point de vue présentée par guillaume
roquette
[Musique]